[Music]
Dylan Farrow says she has felt ignored
for years after alleging that her
adopted father Woody Allen sexually
abused her Allen has denied the
accusations and has never been charged
with a crime but in her first TV
interview about the allegations Dylan
Farrow says she's speaking up again to
have her voice included in The Times up
in me two conversations it's an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning
in over the past two weeks several
celebrities have voiced their support
for Farrell including Natalie Portman
who spoke out on CBS Sunday morning
we showed farewell clip from that
interview Dylan Farrow was visibly moved
by seeing the support from actor Natalie
Portman I believe Dylan I would want to
say that I believe you Dylan Wow
she has been searching for that
acknowledgement most of her life with so
much silence being broken by so many
brave people against so many
high-profile people I felt it was
important to add my story to theirs
because it's something that I've
struggled with for a long time and it
was it was very momentous for me to see
this conversation finally carried into a
public setting as the me2 movement
continues Dylan took to social media to
call out celebrities who have starred in
Woody Allen's films are you angry with
the people with the celebrities that are
starring in his movies that hold him in
high regard and continue to compliment
him I'm not angry with them I hope that
you know especially since so many of
them have been vocal advocates of this
be - in times up movement that they can
acknowledge their complicity and maybe
hold themselves accountable to how they
have perpetuated this culture of of
silence in their industry and how are
they complicit because I have been
saying this I have been repeating my
accusations unaltered for over 20 years
and I have been systematically shut down
ignored or discredited if they can't
acknowledge the accusations of one
survivors how are they going to stand
for all of us
people say it's a family matter it was
many years ago I don't really know the
details of this case so find out I mean
it's it's really like I said it's it's
so easy in this day and age it's a
family matter but here's another thing I
am a real person and I've been
struggling coping on my good days with
the aftershocks of being sexually
assaulted as a small child and that's
real and that matters how has this
affected your life it's affected every
part of my life you know growing up and
like I said I I pushed it to the side I
tried to pretend or tried to convince
myself that this was something moving
forward that I did not need to bring
with me even though it came anyway it's
impacted everything married and a mother
to a 16 month old daughter Dylan is an
advocate for victims of sexual abuse I
have a wonderful husband and I have this
amazing little girl now so what will you
tell her when the time comes what will
you tell her about how to be in this
world that if she was ever in a position
that she's not helpless mm-hmm because
one of the things that I remember very
clearly as a small child is this feeling
of helplessness and if I can give her
some of the tools that I didn't have
then I'm hoping that I will have done
right by her as a parent
well we reach out to the actors at
Ferrell mentioned in her tweet but we
have not heard back this week actor
Timothy sha'lame announced he is
donating his entire salary from his work
in an upcoming Woody Allen movie to the
three charities rather that fights
sexual abuse and harassment including
time's up he wrote this on Instagram I
want to be worthy of standing shoulder
to shoulder with a brave artists who are
fighting for all people to be treated
with the respect and dignity that they
deserve
in a statement to CBS this morning Woody
Allen writes in part even though the
Ferrell family is cynically using the
opportunity afforded by the times of
movement to repeat this discredited
allegation that does not make it any
more true today than it was in the past
I never molested my daughter you can
read his full statement at CBS this
morning calm I'm so impressed by her
courage to speak out about this I was -
Nora and I reached out to her a couple
of days ago and she's you know she's
worried now what will be the reaction to
her telling the truth but she said I
feel that at least even if no one
believes me I at least know that I've
said what I needed to say who she's
concerned that there will be a backlash
I'm saying well we will see